[Music]
in 2008 taylor lautner rose to
prominence as a werewolf jacob black
one third of the supernatural love
triangle in the film adaptation of the
vampire novel twilight
here's why taylor lautner's film career
faltered in the years following the
twilight series
and why he might be poised for a major
comeback
try and keep up after appearing in the
twilight films taylor lautner was known
as much for his physique as he was for
his acting abilities to get in shape to
play jacob
lautner stuck with a strict diet and
exercise routine and his efforts
undeniably paid off
in 2010 lautner ranked number one on
access hollywood's top five hollywood
abs list
but he became frustrated when he
realized that moving forward
every director seemed to focus on his
appearance rather than foster his talent
lautner had a small role in the film
valentine's day and he pushed back
against a scene that was specifically
written for him to show off his abs
lautner explained in an interview with
gq originally i was supposed to take off
my shirt
the script said we were walking into
school and willy takes off his shirt
i said whoa whoa whoa time out he's
gonna take off his shirt in the middle
of school
no no no the reason i took off my shirt
for new moon is because it's written in
the book that way and there's reasons
behind it
lautner wanted to be seen as more than a
pretty face but it was tough to get past
his public image
we can't be friends anymore taylor
lautner has been working in hollywood
for several years before landing the
role of jacob in twilight but there's no
doubt
that this was the role that brought him
fame the final installment in the
twilight franchise was released in 2012
but for better or for worse he's never
really moved past him
in 2015 lautner was still publicly
struggling to decide what his next
career move would be one agent commented
in an interview with the hollywood
reporter
it's not easy to move out of the shadow
of a hit like twilight
but he's still very young there's time
for taylor to become more than just
jacob
while he has landed television roles
since then he hasn't secured a role in a
major film
and he certainly hasn't taken on any
projects that brought him the same level
of publicity as twilight today
lautner is still best known for playing
jacob black a role that has defined his
career for more than a decade
in 2010 taylor lautner was one of the
most expensive teen stars in hollywood
granted the popularity of twilight
basically guaranteed that he would need
a serious paycheck to sign on to future
films
but compared to similar actors lautner
was asking for a very high salary
despite the fact that he had never
opened a film before
when he signed on to the film stretch
armstrong based on the toy of the same
name
his contract reportedly included a 7.5
million dollar salary
at the time this was likely more than
robert pattinson was earning for his
starring roles
in films like remember me lautner might
have felt like he could command that
kind of price while twilight was an
inescapable cultural phenomenon
but as he failed to deliver at the box
office directors became skeptical that
this high price tag was worth it
there was no doubt that he had great
potential but potential wasn't enough
for that kind of paycheck
in 2011 taylor lautner was aiming to
lead a blockbuster that would open up
new opportunities for him after twilight
he starred in the action film abduction
as nathan harper who was secretly given
away to adoptive parents because his
biological parents were trying to
uncover corruption within the cia
still a teenager in the film he's driven
to uncover the truth of what happened to
his family
unfortunately abduction did not premiere
to positive reviews
and it didn't launch an exciting new
phase of lautner's career
who is my father who were my real
parents critic renee rodriguez wrote in
a review for the salt lake tribune
abduction is a crass and lowbrow attempt
to cash in on the young actor's heat an
exploitation picture where the person
being taken advantage of
is too young to notice other critics
also felt that the film was basically an
attempt to profit from loudness fame
before the hype around twilight died
down
with critic stephen holden calling
abduction quote a sloppy exploitative
act of star worship
created around lautner while abduction
was a misstep for taylor lautner's
career
he could always make a comeback with
better films however this comeback has
never really materialized in 2015 he
starred in the film tracers and while
the parkour sequences in his action
movie were certainly entertaining
he still failed to impress critics who
felt that he hadn't broken free of his
image
stephen witty wrote in a review for the
new york daily news hollywood's hunkiest
lunkiest werewolf
is still stuck making movies where his
big stage direction is
he slowly peels off his t-shirt his
foray into comedy with a roll in the
ridiculous six fell flat too
the adam sandler flick earned a dismal
naught percent rating from critics
on rotten tomatoes brad newsome
commented in a review for the sydney
morning herald
it's a lazy pastiche of westerns and
western spoofs replete with lazy
racist jokes that can't just be waved
away with a waft of the irony card
woeful in 2016 taylor lautner starred in
the indie film
run the tide he played raymond who cares
for his younger brother oliver
while the mother is in prison but when
she is released he runs away with his
brother to the california coast
hoping to protect oliver from her abuse
he thinks we can be some sort of family
again
he referred to the movie as a quote
passion project for everyone involved
and he was clearly enthusiastic about
taking on a role that was very different
from anything he had done before
in fact he said he wanted to push back
against his heartthrob status
but unfortunately he still hadn't
managed to please the critics
critic roger moore wrote in a review of
run the tide for movie nation
lautner trots out another sensitive
character that he can't really do
justice to
he's a flat actor never quite able to
bring spark to his roles or make us
forget how hard he has to try just to be
this convincing in a part
the films that taylor lautner starred in
during the years following twilight
didn't find success at the box office
but at least they made it to theaters
there were several other loudness films
that never even saw the light of day
for instance he was slated to appear in
the action film northern lights
but he decided to drop out when he was
offered a major role in stretch
armstrong however this choice didn't
pronounce how he had hoped stretch
armstrong was eventually shelved and the
project was abandoned he also signed on
for a biblical film about the story of
david and goliath but this project
stalled out and never made it to the big
screen either
every actor suffers through his or her
share of projects that don't pan out
but at this point in loudness career
those setbacks were particularly
damaging he was just beginning to make a
name for himself
outside of the twilight franchise after
all when his shooting schedule started
to fall apart
it was difficult to make up the last
opportunities or reverse his rapidly
dwindling momentum
taylor lautner is a bit of a homebody
while he was working on the twilight
films he continued living at home with
his family
outside of los angeles rather than
buying his own house when lautner was
asked about moving out of his family's
home in an interview with gq
he replied there's really no point i'm
so busy
i really haven't thought about it the
thing i love is that my home life hasn't
changed i still help out with the
garbage i still help out with the lawn
while he loved acting he also loved his
life at home and even though his career
was reaching new heights he didn't want
to place himself in the center of
hollywood
and say goodbye to his family home
eventually lautner did decide to embrace
his independence
and strike out on his own more recently
he purchased an expansive mansion in
agora hills where he found several acres
of land and
plenty of privacy taylor lautner has
dated several women in hollywood
he's been linked to taylor swift olivia
holt and more recently his scream
queen's co-star billy lord
but since 2018 lautner has been happily
settled down with his girlfriend
taylor dome who was not a celebrity in
2018
lautner posted a picture of the couple
in their halloween costumes on instagram
and the two have continued to share
adorable photos ever since
dome is a nurse who likely met lauter
after becoming friends with his younger
sister
and she doesn't spend her life in the
spotlight perhaps spending more time
with his girlfriend has led lartner to
focus on life outside of hollywood
after being in several relationships
that were constantly scrutinized by the
press
dating someone who doesn't work in the
entertainment industry might be a relief
a couple has been together for years and
they certainly seem to be quite happy
although taylor lorna's film career has
lost momentum in the years since
twilight
he might have a bright future in tv in
2016 he joined the cast of scream queens
as dr cassidy cascade
a zombie who decided to study medicine
because he couldn't understand what he'd
become
and in 2014 he took on an unexpected
role
in the british comedy cuckoo in cuckoo
lautner starred as dale
a young naive american who was searching
for his father the title character
goku a carefree hippie had gone missing
in a climbing accident but dale crashes
with his wife's family hoping to find
some sort of connection
lalner established himself as a
surprisingly skilled comedy actor in the
role
i mean do you know what that's called
maybe just put shoe whirly thing kayla
cobb wrote in a review for decider
dale isn't funny because he's being
played by the icon of team jacob
dale's funny because lautner dominates
in the series dale is a clueless
american who has recently left
a confusing cult and his funniest
moments stem from his bizarre balance of
unrelenting optimism
and cluelessness perhaps this role has
opened up some doors for lautner he's
kept in touch with his cuckoo co-star
greg davies who spoke highly of his
experience working
with lautner maybe taylor lautner's best
work is yet to come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]